hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with cinnamon toast ken hey
how you doing hi John we're gonna be
cleaning up some viscera or whatever you
would got blood and guts all right kid
listen to me I know you're eager and
ready to go but it's cleaning operation
it's gonna change oh my god no no I know
I'm so excited I know kid just calm down
it's gonna be blood all over the walls
dead body parts everywhere points you
gotta have to keep her cool at all times
okay don't just follow my lead you'll
see that blood up on the vent you clean
up that spot I'll start over here okay
okay all right good like this yes I
don't know what you're doing but you
better do it good I think I did a good
boss I think I sound like Santa Claus
more than anything can a present no you
cannot have a present okay well you knew
my whoa whoa whoa would you do is you
take the bloody mop after you mop up the
blood all right junk it in the bucket no
get rid of the blood and then you just
start smooshing your mop all over the
place to get more of the blood Wow boss
you're amazing thanks kid I know oh all
right so what'd you do to pick up the
body parts he's got to grab them with
your hands like so to bribe that with
your hands the firmly grasp it firmly
grasp it good
firmly rock solid all right kid you're
not doing so good just pick up those
body parts put them in this bin over
here and make sure that it doesn't get
in the don't put it in the bucket of
water because I'll make the bucket of
water bloody and you don't want that no
don't this look does the bucket water
get bloody after we yeah yes it does a
little bit at a time but you know I'll
be get a bit two more so just be careful
and clean up these damn footprints there
vos Mimi I think you're making more than
up shut up kid I'm the crusty old
janitor here you don't know what's best
I'm sorry boss here you get
cleaning all right you say cleaning okay
I'll check up on you again watch out for
any alien sticking around in the corner
there's aliens whoopee what do you think
all these body parts I thought they were
dead nobody's here anymore
yeah well yes the body parts are dead
but there may still be aliens lurking in
the corners just wanting to nibble on
your giblets much impotence yeah your
tasty giblets what is this the funds to
which that's a useless piece of crumpled
paper we're here to pick up the body
parts kid so pay attention
yes sir all right with this you see this
bucket of blood it's bloody
yes it's bloody we can't use this
anymore it's no good if you dip it over
it'll spray blood anywhere so you gotta
get a new bucket by pressing the button
on this thingy see this okay take this
bucket there you go good job you firmly
grasp and grasp now go down in that
corner coral Court Court actually you
know what screw that you stay here I'm
gonna give me the bucket
give me the a bucket kid thank you all
right no you're getting on my nerves
oh sorry hey I'm trying real hard you
just stay here clean up the body parts
I'll be over here working alone yeah I
do my best work alone yeah good damn
Billy making a mess over here who's in
charge how you doing over there kid
uh I think it's clean it's clean over
there I don't see any blower you sure uh
I come over there and it's not clean ah
I think so uh what's all this then wait
what's going in this what's all that
that doesn't look clean buddy kid you're
never gonna make it in this town I'm
gonna get you another water bug and
we'll say let me do about that all right
way ooo let's calm down here calm down
take a step back and relax okay all
right kid I'm gonna leave you in charge
of something you're gonna get a new
bucket of water
you could clean this mess up but if I
see one single spot of blood I'm gonna
strangle you
oh my bare head okay are you it get get
the new bucket you know do you know how
uh uh the red button the red button
press the red button there you go good
job kid
you might survive the alien invasion
after all hope so oh yeah you get that
bucket you splash it around a little bit
put it on the floor get down there
dirty get out your mop your big long mop
me like that I like that it's good let's
touch mom's little bloody hope we don't
mind and it's that time of the month run
off I'm sorry yeah yeah it's okay don't
worry about it it's perfectly sanitary I
like to weigh the tendrils okay that's
getting a little weird
all right I'm gonna go over there with a
fresh bucket and okay there we go and
you just clean up over here okay okay
okay I'm gonna come back at your damn
bot okay
why all right you know what just take
that bucket that I got and just use it I
I can't believe it kid
I can't believe the aliens didn't kill
you and they killed my wife instant
where'd you take my bucket you drew out
a bunch of [ __ ] over there how where why
we're here right your doctor water out
correct
I'm gonna throw you in the insert' did
you know that there's an incinerator
around here kid no you know I'm gonna
throw you in it if you cause me more
trouble oh oh here it is over here okay
but you're now useless to me yet kid Oh
stick to the plan and we'll get out of
here alive wait weak and uh yes we can
die don't you notice all the dead people
around here about it they said on they
said it was what that it was safe yes
just sent us in here alone so that we
could do our jobs
right kid be scared I'm scared it's a
scary world out there what are you doing
with the bucket of what I owe your mommy
to hold you of it yeah
just Curie wait a minute something wrong
with your eyes look they're pure white
what do with you yes me today Lee did
you add any of the blood no touchie mops
did you feel any touch your eyes
I think something's wrong with the boss
that's don't know who you talking to
some severed head over there is that
Jimmy Jimmy saying bad things about me
you're not answering my question kid
what are you asking me in the head oh
wait what are you talking to
I was wrong with you I still get bloody
mob here you want to touch mops again
please mobs yes yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah clean all that up ok
boss ha ha I like how you're still loyal
even though our vibe
I'm absolutely shown that I'm not fit
like I'm trapped in here with you got to
be here just just come a little closer
as we both stand by the incinerator yeah
I'm sure it'll be fine doodlee Hey look
at juicy tours oh let's feed in amnesia
monster ok shut up
now that game huh all right kid one last
thing ok with me I need to show you how
the incinerator works the the insanity
and the sinner rater are your kid hey
good it's a kid okay come here okay I'm
coming come here you're walking a little
slow there hmm so what happened you know
come closer come closer kid okay so you
take anything that's been infected by
aliens and you just grab on to it and
you shove it into the incinerator and it
goes away forever forever forever where
does it go it goes away forever well you
made where does it go it away forever
he's gonna go somewhere right it goes
away forever
okay get real close in there you'll get
it real good
became real good lucky boys we had okay
good fuss
get that one right there okay I'll get
it yeah I'm on my hands and knees what
you like to keep on going I'm going boy
don't go he's going I seem to be
spreading things around walk yes ready
using all over bought like butter it's
getting real dirty in your boy so dirty
did the way I like it
such a dirty boy mark I tried why you
going